papa s'il te plaît sans mon nouveau
parfum
maman s'il te plaît
[Musique]
Jean-Pierre est-ce que tu reviens
bientôt
parce que nous ennuyons de toi et moi la
première c'est tellement sympathique
voilà Jean-Pierre c'est mon dernier mot
ma chère Jean-Claude je te remercie je
savais très bien que je te manquais
énormément et bien c'est une bonne
nouvelle non je ne reviens pas sauf pour
les Miss France ce serait une fois par
an pendant combien de temps Dieu seul le
sait je t'embrasse
tu triches ou quoi
je ne réponds
[Musique]
alors cette par-là elle est pour Bernard
Arnault une part pour les actionnaires
de Total cette par-là elle va pour le
patron de beurre et la dernière pour
mckinsee
de la France
toutes les personnes qui me disent oh
mais tu prends des écouteurs affiliés
les prochains Paillard pod c'est mes
oreilles je fais ce que je veux voilà
moi j'aime bien comme ça voilà arrêtez
de m'inviter
[Musique]
je m'en vais